Queridos amigos, ¿y si os dijera que Texas
podría llegar a independizarse de Estados
Unidos?
No, no es ninguna broma.
Igual que ocurre con los movimientos independentistas
de Escocia, Quebec o Cataluña, Estados Unidos
también tiene su propia versión de todos
esos embrollos políticos.
Fijaos:
N1(1 diciembre 2023: Texas, un paso más cerca
de abandonar EE.UU.
- Newsweek)
Sí, tal y como lo estáis oyendo.
Aunque resulte difícil de creer, Texas tiene
su propio movimiento independentista.
Uno nostálgico con aquella Texas independiente
que logró separarse de México en 1836 y
que desapareció en 1845 con la adhesión
a Estados Unidos.
De hecho, a semejanza del Brexit, al caso
de Texas algunos le conocen ya como “Texit”.
Y ojo, porque esto no es una ida de olla.
El movimiento es pequeño, pero está cogiendo
fuerza, y desde luego sucesos como los acontecidos
en las últimas semanas no ayudan precisamente
a calmar los ánimos.
N2(25 enero 2024: Se intensifica el enfrentamiento
fronterizo entre Texas y los federales mientras
el gobernador desafía la decisión del Tribunal
Supremo – PBS News Hour)
Exacto, el gobierno de Texas y la administración
Biden han comenzado el 2024 inmersos en una
fuerte disputa por el control de la frontera
de Texas con México.
La situación está que arde.
Ahora bien, exactamente…
¿Qué está ocurriendo en la frontera de
Texas como para alimentar un movimiento independentista?
¿Por qué Texas quiere ocuparse por si mismo
del control de sus fronteras?
¿Podría la inmigración ser la gota que
colma el vaso y terminar con un movimiento
independentista bien formado?
Pues bien, todo esto y más os lo vamos a
contar a continuación.
Atentos.
[Por cierto, no te olvides de que ya hemos
lanzado nuestro nuevo canal de negocios: El
Informe K.
Muchísimas gracias a todos por la acogida
tan buena que le estáis dando.
Si aún no lo conocéis os dejo el link en
la descripción.
Ya nos dirás que te parece]
T1(LA ETERNA CRISIS FRONTERIZA)
Si habéis estado atentos a las noticias últimamente,
puede que hayáis visto decenas de imágenes
y titulares sobre la frontera entre Estados
Unidos y México.
Y no es para menos, el tío Sam está sufriendo
una de las peores crisis fronterizas de las
últimas décadas, por no decir de toda su
historia.
Desde que Joe Biden tomó las riendas de la
Casa Blanca en enero de 2021 hasta el pasado
diciembre de 2023, la Patrulla Fronteriza
de Estados Unidos ha interceptado a más de
6 millones de personas.
Sí, sí, habéis oído bien.
¡Seis millones!
Es como si en menos de tres años un país
entero como Dinamarca quisiera entrar ilegalmente
en Estados Unidos.
Como os podéis imaginar, con semejante percal
las autoridades fronterizas están desbordadas.
Tan solo en diciembre de 2023, han llegado
a procesar a 10.000 personas…
por día!
De locos.
Pero es que es más, aun así, según los
datos del Departamento de Seguridad Nacional,
en ese mismo periodo, entre un millón y medio
y dos millones de indocumentados han cruzado
de manera ilegal la frontera.
Por eso, desde el Partido Republicano se ha
acusado a Biden de fomentar una política
de fronteras abiertas.
Ahora bien, ¿es esto realmente cierto?
Pues… no, para nada.
Es cierto que las peticiones de asilo aceptadas
han crecido con respecto a la era Trump, pero
esto se debe sobre todo a que simplemente
se han disparado las solicitudes.
De hecho, a grandes rasgos, Biden está llevando
una política migratoria bastante continuista
con la del gobierno de Trump.
Por ejemplo, ha mantenido el acuerdo con México
por el que los deportados por Estados Unidos
son llevados directamente a su vecino del
sur.
Además, la inversión en seguridad fronteriza
y aduanera también se ha mantenido en el
entorno de los $15.000 millones anuales, e
incluso por encima de esta cifra récord algunos
años.
Pero, entonces, muchos os estaréis preguntando…
¿Qué diantres está fallando?
¿Por qué se han disparado tanto las llegadas
de inmigrantes a la frontera sur de Estados
Unidos?
Pues, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,las
razones no las vamos a encontrar dentro de
Estados Unidos.
Y es que, fijaos un momento en este gráfico.
La situación de los países iberoamericanos
en algunos casos está empeorando.
La corrupción, la violencia y la pobreza
siguen siendo, por desgracia, la norma en
países como México, Venezuela o en regiones
como el Triángulo Norte, sobre todo en Guatemala
y Honduras.
Puede que solo El Salvador se salve de esta
tendencia tan negativa que se está viendo
últimamente en Iberoamérica.
Es más, los que hayáis visto nuestro reciente
vídeo de Ecuador sabréis por dónde van
los tiros.
Y es que, en estos últimos años, noticias
como esta no han hecho más que multiplicarse.
N3(25 de enero de 2022: La pobreza extrema
en la región sube a 86 millones en 2021 como
consecuencia de la profundización de la crisis
social y sanitaria derivada de la pandemia
de Covid-19 – CEPAL)
(12 de mayo de 2023: América Latina lucha
contra una nueva ola de criminalidad – International
Crisis Group)
Eso sí, a diferencia de Trump, que simplemente
criminalizaba a los inmigrantes, Biden ha
intentado atajar esta crisis poniendo el foco
en las causas de la inmigración ilegal
Es decir: la corrupción, la pobreza y la
inseguridad.
Por ejemplo, se ha ido sancionando a altos
funcionarios centroamericanos envueltos en
importantes casos de corrupción en lo que
se conoce como “Lista Engel”.
También la vicepresidente Kamala Harris,
que es la encargada de la política migratoria
en esta administración, ha impulsado un programa
de inversiones de más de 4.000 millones de
dólares.
Sin embargo, para muchos, todo esto está
siendo inútil.
Una pérdida de tiempo y de dinero.
Y es que claro, el problema que tiene apostar
por este tipo de estrategias es que los resultados
no son precisamente rápido.
Quizás pueda ser una buena idea a medio y
largo plazo, pero no antes.
Y el problema es que los estadounidenses están
ansiosos por conseguir soluciones.
Y aquí es justo aquí donde aparece Texas
con su gobernador, el republicano Greg Abbot,
para dar un puñetazo en la mesa.
Atentos.
T2(ABBOTT VS BIDEN)
¿Recordáis que os hemos dicho que entre
2021 y 2023 Estados Unidos interceptó a 6
millones de inmigrantes en su frontera?
Pues bien, casi el 60% de ellos fueron interceptados
en suelo tejano.
Por eso en 2021 el gobernador de Texas, Greg
Abbott, lanzó la Operación Lone Star, o
traducido a español, Estrella Solitaria.
Con esta iniciativa, el gobierno de Texas
desplegó a su Guardia Nacional y otras agencias
de seguridad del Estado en la frontera.
De esta forma, Texas empezó a tomar sus propias
medidas de acción, como, por ejemplo, desplegar
grandes barreras subacuáticas con boyas en
el Río Grande para impedir el paso por el
río a los migrantes
Y eso no es todo, el pasado diciembre de 2023
también firmó una ley que permitía a la
policía del Estado detener a los inmigrantes
que entraran de manera ilegal por su frontera.
Y además, de acuerdo a esta ley, los propios
jueces del Estado también podrían ordenar
su deportación, algo que en Estados Unidos
llevan jueces específicos del Departamento
de Justicia.
Y sí, obviamente tal y como estáis pensando,
eso supone todo un desafío contra el gobierno
federal.
Y por si eso fuera poco, todo saltó por los
aires por una medida concreta que Abbott adoptó
en septiembre de 2023: el despliegue de más
de 70.000 rollos de alambre de espino a manos
de la Guardia Nacional de Texas.
Ahora bien, una batalla ganada no supone una
victoria en toda la guerra.
El conflicto con el gobierno federal apenas
ha hecho nada más que comenzar, y para prueba
esto.
Escuchad.
N5(12 de enero de 2024: Los federales dicen
que Texas está bloqueando a la Patrulla Fronteriza
de una sección de la frontera, piden a la
Corte Suprema de EE.UU. que intervenga
Sí, la Guardia Nacional de Texas valló todo
un parque de la ciudad de Eagle Pass y denegó
la entrada a la Patrulla Fronteriza.
La reacción de la administración Biden no
se hizo esperar: presentaron documentos al
Tribunal Supremo que demostraban la importancia
de ese acceso para socorrer a los inmigrantes
que hubiesen tenido problemas al cruzar el
río y que estuvieran en peligro de ahogarse.
(Y no es para menos.
El día 12 de enero, una mujer mexicana se
ahogó con sus dos hijos menores de edad a
orillas de Eagle Pass.
Con esta presión tan grande, el Tribunal
Supremo finalmente decidió permitir a la
Patrulla Fronteriza retirar todo el alambre
de espino, ya que tiene jurisdicción en todo
el territorio fronterizo del país.
Sin embargo, lo que no hicieron fue prohibirle
a la Guardia Nacional de Texas que siguiera
desplegándolo, algo que el propio gobernador
ha dicho que seguirán haciendo.)
El caso es que, en el momento en el que preparamos
este vídeo, la Guardia Nacional todavía
no ha dado acceso al parque de Eagle Pass
a la Patrulla Fronteriza.
Creen que lo convertirán en otro punto de
entrada para la inmigración ilegal.
Y en esta especie de guerra entre Texas y
el gobierno federal, el gobernador Abbott
no está precisamente solo…
Casi todos los gobernadores republicanos del
país y el propio Donald Trump han apoyado
esta decisión y la postura de Abbott.
De hecho, incluso han aumentado el envío
de soldados de sus propias guardias nacionales
para apoyar al gobernador tejano.
La situación como veis está al rojo vivo.
El viejo espíritu independiente de Texas
está dejándose notar como no lo hacía en
mucho tiempo, y muchos hablan ya de una posible
secesión tejana como esto termine yendo a
mayores.
La cuestión es…
¿Es esto realmente posible?
¿Puede Texas separarse de Estados Unidos?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T3(¿RUMBO AL TEXIT?)
Las medidas de Abbott en materia de control
migratorio y el encontronazo con las autoridades
de Washington DC están en cierto modo impulsando
el Movimiento Nacionalista de Texas.
Y si no me creéis, fijaos:
N6(23 de enero de 2024: Cómo la lucha fronteriza
de Greg Abbott refuerza los llamamientos a
un Texas independiente - Newsweek)
N7(30 de enero de 2024: El enfrentamiento
de Texas con los federales en Eagle Pass enciende
los llamamientos a la secesión y el temor
a la violencia - The Texas Tribune)
La causa independentista tejana ha sido una
de las pocas que no murió ni quedó enterrada
en el olvido tras la Guerra Civil de Estados
Unidos.
Y sí, es verdad que Texas no se implicó
mucho en las batallas, pero sí que intentó
independizarse en 1861 al considerar la abolición
de la esclavitud una grave intromisión del
gobierno federal en sus propios asuntos.
Sin embargo, con la victoria del norte, Texas
no pudo independizarse.
Eso sí poco a poco fueron desarrollando una
identidad muy marcada, una identidad muy ligada
al legado de los cowboys y al sudeste de los
Estados Unidos.
(De hecho, a mediados de los años 90, nació
un movimiento conocido como República de
Texas, que se autodenomina, si, podéis creerme,
como “gobierno provisional”.
Este movimiento fue creado por Richard Lance
McLaren, que denunció en incontables ocasiones
al gobierno federal por cosas tan locas como
por ejemplo el paganismo.
Es más, en 1997 hasta reclamó una compensación
a la administración Clinton de más de 90.000
millones de dólares por los daños sufridos
durante la Guerra Civil.)
Pero, anécdotas aparte, el legado secesionista
de Texas va más allá, y está yendo más
allá, hasta el punto de que a día de hoy
nos podemos encontrar noticias como estas:
N8(6 de marzo de 2023: Un legislador de Texas
presenta el proyecto de ley "Texit" para impulsar
la votación sobre la exploración de la secesión
de EE.UU.
- The Hill)
Ahora bien, ¿qué dice el Partido Republicano
de todo esto?
Pues bien, lógicamente el GOP no está por
la labor de incluir un referéndum de independencia
de Texas en el debate político.
Y mucho menos hacerlo de cara a las primarias
de marzo.
Y si no lo hacen, no es tanto porque les guste
más o menos la idea, sino basicamente porque
no pueden.
Una sentencia de 1869 prohíbe tanto a Texas
como a cualquier otro Estado del país independizarse
unilateralmente.
Es decir, que por mucho que algunos políticos
tejanos como Ted Cruz tonteen con los que
defienden la idea de la secesión, no es más
que palabrería política barata para intentar
así mostrar su desacuerdo con Washington.
Es una retórica que, si bien se ha fortalecido
por el enfrentamiento entre Texas y la administración
Biden, no tiene mayor recorrido.
La inmensa mayoría de los tejanos se sienten
muy estadounidenses.
¡Faltaría más!
Incluso aunque les encante ser tejanos.
[Ya sabéis, que vivan los cowboys]
De hecho, es probable que una vez se solucione
todo esto, el tema vuelva a enterrarse y limitarse
prácticamente a entornos muy minoritarios.
Así que ya lo veis, los sueños de los secesionistas
tejanos tienen las patitas muy cortas y se
quedaran, seguramente en eso, en sueños.
Pero lo que no es tan minoritario ni intrascendente
es la dura batalla que está germinando entre
los republicanos y la Administración Biden
a las puertas de unas elecciones a la Casa
Blanca, al Senado y al Congreso.
.
Amigos, las cosas prometen estar entretenidas
para bien o para mal en los próximos meses.
De momento, el turno ahora es para vosotros:
¿creéis que se calmarán pronto las tensiones
entre Abbott y Biden o irán todavía a peor?
¿Podría ganar peso la retórica secesionista
en Texas?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas aquí
abajo, en los comentarios.
Y muy importante, si os ha gustado este vídeo
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
nuestro canal para no perderos ninguna novedad.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.